in the third millennium BCE Mesopotamian
Kings recorded and interpreted their
dreams on wax tablets a thousand years
later ancient Egyptians wrote a dream
book listing over a hundred common
dreams and their meanings and in the
years since we haven't paused in our
quest to understand why we dream so
after a great deal of scientific
research technological advancement and
persistence we still don't have any
definite answers but we have some
interesting theories
we dream to fulfill our wishes in the
early 1900's Sigmund Freud proposed that
while all of our dreams including our
nightmares are a collection of images
from our daily conscious lives they also
have symbolic meanings which relate to
the fulfillment of our subconscious
wishes
Freud theorized that everything we
remember when we wake up from a dream is
a symbolic representation of our
unconscious primitive thoughts urges and
desires Freud believed that by analyzing
those remembered elements the
unconscious content would be revealed to
our conscious mind and psychological
issues stemming from its repression
could be addressed and resolved we dream
to remember to increase performance on
certain mental tasks sleep is good but
dreaming while sleeping is better in
2010 researchers found that subjects
were much better at getting through a
complex 3d maze if they had napped and
dreamed of the maze prior to their
second attempt in fact they were up to
ten times better at it than those who
only thought of the maze while awake
between attempts and those who nabbed
but did not dream about the maze
researchers theorized that certain
memory processes can happen only when we
are asleep and our dreams are a signal
that these processes are taking place
we dream to forget there are about
10,000 trillion neural connections
within the architecture of your brain
they are created by everything you think
and everything you do a 1983
neurobiological theory of dreaming
called reverse learning holds that while
sleeping and mainly during REM sleep
cycles your neocortex reviews these
neural connections and dumps the
unnecessary ones without this unlearning
process which results in your dreams
your brain could be overrun by useless
connections and parasitic thoughts could
disrupt the necessary thinking you need
to do while you're awake
we dream to keep our brains working the
continual activation theory proposes
that your dreams result from your brains
need to constantly consolidate and
create long term memories in order to
function properly so when external input
falls below a certain level like when
you're asleep your brain automatically
triggers the generation of data from its
memory storages which appear to you in
the form of the thoughts and feelings
you experience in your dreams in other
words your dreams might be a random
screensaver your brain turns on so it
doesn't completely shut down
we dream to rehearse dreams involving
dangerous and threatening situations are
very common and the primitive instinct
rehearsal theory holds that the content
of a dream is significant to its purpose
whether it's an anxiety filled night of
being chased through the woods by a bear
or fighting off a ninja in a dark alley
these dreams allow you to practice your
fight or flight instincts and keep them
sharp and dependable in case you'll need
them in real life but it doesn't always
have to be unpleasant for instance
dreams about your attractive neighbor
could actually give your reproductive
instinct some practice - we dream to
heal stress neurotransmitters in the
brain are much less active during the
REM stage of sleep even during dreams of
traumatic experiences leading some
researchers to theorize that one purpose
of dreaming is to take the edge off
painful experiences to allow for
psychological healing reviewing
traumatic events in your dreams with
less mental stress may grant you a
clearer perspective and an enhanced
ability to process them in
psychologically healthy ways people with
certain mood disorders and PTSD often
have difficulty sleeping leading some
scientists to believe that lack of
dreaming may be a contributing factor to
their illnesses
we dream to solve problems unconstrained
by reality and the rules of conventional
logic in your dreams your mind can
create limitless scenarios to help you
grasp problems and formulate solutions
that you may not consider while awake
John Steinbeck called it the Committee
of sleep and research has demonstrated
the effectiveness of dreaming on problem
solving it's also how renowned chemist
August kekulé discovered the structure
of the benzene molecule and is the
reason that sometimes the best solution
for a problem is to sleep on it and
those are just a few of the more
prominent theories as technology
increases our capability for
understanding the brain it's possible
that one day we will discover the
definitive reason for them but until
that time arrives we'll just have to
keep on dreaming